there's a video going around tik tok
uh every time i say that
ever i just i i myself get a little
chill up my spine nothing good generally
goes around tik tok there's a video of a
sexually confused man who
who i guess identifies as a woman who
now claims
that if you not only do we need to
indulge his delusions not only do we
need to indulge the crack addict and
give him pipes not only do we need to
indulge the thief and give him gucci
bags not only do we need to indulge the
sexually confused guy and pretend that
he's a woman
but if we do not actively participate in
that if we do not
sleep
with the sexually confused guy
we are bigots
so if the only reason you don't want to
date someone boils down to the fact
they're trans that's transphobia right
there let's go over a couple of
situations so if you don't want to date
a trans woman because you want kids
well you better be keeping that same
attitude with cis women who are
infertile or that's transphobia
if you don't want to date a trans woman
because you're not attracted to trans
women i would absolutely love to know
how you're able to identify correctly
who is the trans woman on site 100 of
the time because that is just impressive
i wish i had that ability i'd love to be
able to have even more trans solidarity
and then also just
being super straight is the all lives
matter of sexualities it's not a real
sexuality it literally is just something
that's made up to make fun of trans
people and to hate on trans people so
yes super straights i don't respect you
and i don't respect that sexuality bye
if i found out today
that these videos are not being produced
in america they're not being produced by
just random people that these are all
being filmed in beijing
in xi jinping's propaganda studio to
disseminate throughout the west and
destroy our civilization i would be
about
seven percent surprised no three percent
surprised
this is
really
really bad
it is and frankly it's even worse if
this is not just propaganda intended to
destroy your civilization because it
means that our civilization's already
been rotted out so much from the inside
that this is just naturally happening
the claim here
is that
if
if you
can tell the difference between a man in
a dress
and a woman
then you are
a bigot
he's really saying you can't no one can
tell the difference right he it doesn't
he looks like marilyn monroe doesn't he
you couldn't tell that line them up you
couldn't possibly tell the difference
right and if you
if you want to uh
marry a woman instead of a man
pretending to be a woman
well
that's that's just evidence of your
small-mindedness what you mean because
women can conceive children and men
can't well then
what so you would never marry an
infertile woman well what does what do
you even mean by that what is
if you're telling me that the only
difference between men in dresses and
women
is that
women
can produce babies i mean that's a
pretty big difference but there are
other differences
as well this is clearly a disturbed
individual this is a man who's very very
confused about
himself about nature and about the rules
he should be helped a good society would
try to help this guy not to indulge his
delusion and his fantasy
a healthy society should should try to
help the crack addict not by giving him
crack not by giving him a crack pipe
the good society should try to help the
thief not by giving him nikes and gucci
handbags but by saying no don't do that
uh-uh that's bad if you do that if
you're a thief if you're a crack addict
if you mutilate your body you're gonna
have a bad life that's not gonna help
you flourish and so we're gonna help you
by laying out the rules men are supposed
to be men and women are supposed to be
women and men cannot become women and
women cannot become men and men and
women go together they are complementary
and they they come together and they
form a marriage and then they can
produce children
and not everyone can produce children
it's a fallen world there are
imperfections we all suffer we all carry
our cross but that's the that's the way
the world is ordered there are rules
there is a purpose
not only to life broadly but to the
individual things in life and we can
know something about that purpose and
that's how we're going to order society
you're not allowed to say any of that
you're not if you try to help that guy
right now if you sat him down and said
hey buster you are not a woman it is not
wrong or unjust or bigoted for a dude
not to want to sleep with you you need
to you need to stop pretending to be a
woman because it's not helping you or
anyone else and we're going to try to
get you some counseling if you did that
in canada you would be arrested
if that if that guy were your son and
you did that in canada you would lose
your son you might lose your kid here in
america in many places
if you were a teacher who said hey
you're not we want to help you and you'd
be booted out you'd be kicked out
you'd be fired
there's a law now in canada
if you sat down a guy who knows that
he's a guy
and said hey
you're actually a woman
that would be totally fine
you sit down that guy who thinks he's a
woman you say you're a guy you could be
arrested for it
there are still rules it's just that the
rules are are in the
direction of delusion
and
falsehood so
the way we think of it now the way on
the left and on parts of the right
actually is that the rules are bad they
don't let us be free look if that man
wants to
pretend that he's a woman and mutilate
himself that's fine that's his right man
you know hey if the crack addict wants
to smoke a bunch of crack that's fine
and on the left they say we're gonna pay
for you to smoke the crack and on the
right they say don't make me pay for
your crack but you can go smoke crack if
you want but both of those are wrong
don't smoke the crack okay that is these
are basic rules if you're a man don't
mutilate yourself and pretend to be a
woman and if you're a crack addict put
down the pipe do not take the pipe the
rules are not oppressive
repression itself is not oppressive if
repression is is repressing bad desires
that enslave you to bad appetites the
rules can be a great source of strength
and comfort did you like that clip
i'm glad you liked that i liked the clip
as well i liked that you liked it if you
want to get more of them subscribe get
notifications
right here ring that bell
if you don't get notifications because
our friends at youtube don't want you to
for whatever reason head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe to the michael
knowles show leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]